[Music]
foreign
you are the Godmother of soul
a Grammy winner a cookbook author and an
entrepreneur and you are here for the
Forbes and know your value 50 over 50.
thank you so much for sitting down thank
you for thinking of me oh my goodness so
happy to be here I want to talk about
your food line it is doing very very
well how long have you been cooking do
you remember when you learned how to
cook I learned to cook when I was about
10. watching my mother and father
I would go to the garage and make up hot
sauces and ketchup and I would add
mustard to the ketchup and make another
taste like it had a spicy I had a mild
and I had a sweet ketchups and hot sauce
real hot hot sauce and then you were
performing and I understand that you
have cooked for some musical Legends
including John Elton John John was my
piano player
in London he had a group called
bluesology and his name was Reggie
Dwight back then and so they had no
pounds you know money they had no money
and after the shows I would take them to
our Loft and I would make dinner for the
band and they would always want to take
something back because they had no money
they were hungry and so I let them take
my Tupperware so anyway
Elton called me one day he said Patty I
said how are you Reggie he called me as
Reggie that's that's the way he said I
would like for you to come to the
Spectrum tonight I'm performing I said
who are you opening for he said I'm
Elton John I said you're who
you're out the job my piano player and
the first thing I said to him was now
you can afford to give me my Tupperware
back
and I didn't get the Tupperware back I
got a diamond ring upgrade yeah upgrade
and he was performing in Vegas so we
recorded a duet for my album and as he
was playing the piano he had to take his
rings off so when he finished I said
Elton there's your jewelry he said no
that ring is yours for the Tupperware
you know and that that was my story with
Elton and Richard Pryor the Rolling
Stones came to Philly and begged me to
cook some food to send to the spec the
Spectrum I did and so I said as long as
my name is on all of my uh aluminum foil
tops so because we always have caterers
in every city we go different people
will cook for the artist I said make
sure you make sure my food is separate
from the caterers
and they separated my food and I was
viral after that people were saying
Patti LaBelle can cook she cook for the
stones and just so many different people
in the industry just love my cooking you
cooked for the stones and you said make
sure the tin foil says Patti LaBelle why
was it so important for you to put your
name on what you provided because with
my heart I cook and my food is so good I
don't want anybody else taking credit
for it I mean I cook my face off I've
always cooked and I've always wanted
people to realize it's me cooking that
because a lot of entertainers will come
into my house back in the day they said
we want to see you cook of course love
had been begging me to cook for him so
it was a Thanksgiving and this is when I
was living in my other house and he
would come over and he were some of the
band members he said I want to see you
cook so he watched me make potato salad
and I made uh I think it was Branzino
saute Branzino and he said you really
cooked it I said look at my stove it's
all dirty I don't get take out and
pretend that I made it a lot of people
would do that but he saw that I really
cook I love to cook so whenever I do
something for you you better put my name
on it you know that's a No-No if you
don't put Patty's name on her food yeah
I love to cook so you want credit for
your work I have to get credit yes you
deserve credit for your life I sure do
so Martha Stewart invites you on her
show during the holiday season during
busy times yes and you realize there's
an audience for your for your food and
and all of the friends of mine would
always say why don't you open a
restaurant or start your own line of
food and zory sort of quietly bragged my
son uh but he knew that I could really
throw down and Alex all the guys that
are working for me now they were they
started me thinking about how good my
food was so was that the beginning of
Patty's good life that was the beginning
it was Patty's good life what made you
want to do Patty's good life what made
you want to start the company because I
have great taste because I designed I
decorate my house I had the bedding at
Macy's because I love beautiful sheets
and spreads and
drapes and just everything I'm all about
good looking stuff and things that will
be affordable
to the normal person and so it's like
with the food line my food is very
affordable and um I don't put my name on
anything unless it's 110 perfect
and so I knew I could cook
it's no joke I mean I'm not bragging
it's like I said I knew I could sing I'm
not bragging certain things you know you
do well
and sometimes you pat yourself on the
back
and so far this food line has done so
much wonders for me just things are just
happening
you make it sound like magic but I think
it's the result of good taste and hard
work it's not magic it's definitely not
Magic No it's it's hard work and my team
they were like I gave birth to all of
them I mean they're my babies and they
believed in me more so than I believed
in myself because it took a while for me
to say oh what that pie is great but I
had to test it about 10 times before I
said yes to the pie
you actually started with hot sauce and
barbecue sauce yes and then the sweet
potato pie and the sweet potato pie came
in 2015. yes 2015 and that's when
Walmart wanted my recipe and my pie
and
yeah and yeah that yeah covers a viral
video yeah one pie every second the
video from James Chanel that was awesome
and we were in London and somebody sent
the video of his commercial to Zuri I
said who was that and we had no clue but
this guy was loving the pies and thank
God they were selling before he made
that video but after the video it went
viral and people started buying those
pies like crazy but Patty's good
luck I have a breakfast line I have some
things that I can't tell you yet I have
wine coming I have a bunch of food a
bunch of desserts a bunch of um skews of
Frozen Foods so if you have your dinner
if you buy the turkey I have all your
sides you don't have to make anything
and then after the size you can do the
desserts but in the morning it's so
important now we have this breakfast
line coming with pancakes and waffles
and whenever my grandkids will come here
I would always make them breakfast and
they love waffles and so their faces are
on my box of waffles little cute faces
you say Grandma we love these waffles
you know so I have a line of powdered
pancake mix coming of syrup for the
waffles and pancakes and all that is
coming soon
how do you choose what food to offer
through Patty's good life how did you
decide on pancakes how did you decide on
wine as the next I decided on pancakes
because of my grandkids because they
love breakfast and I have the wine line
coming and it's going to be affordable
like 14.95 or something like that that
people can afford to eat my food and
knowing they're getting quality food and
you didn't spend your last dollar for it
so that's important to me so I could
help help someone have a decent meal you
know what this time is hard times are
hard I was going to ask it seems like
affordability is a big goal for you why
is that so important to you and to
Patty's good life because friends always
love my food they say why don't you put
out a line I said okay when I do put
this line out it's going to be
affordable because some of my friends
didn't have much and so when the line
came out I mean they just they just they
were loving the fact that they could
afford a great meal and so it's
important to me to make things
affordable to anyone inflation has been
high and budgets have been tight I think
a lot of people are feeling the need to
find the most affordable options but
still have a really nice meal and they
know with Patti LaBelle that I'm not
going to cheat them I'm not going to lie
to them I'm not going to say it's great
when it's awful my food is phenomenal
and very affordable so it's very
important to me to keep my line
affordable
like with the wine you know oh gosh
Caymans cost about 80 or 180 a bottle or
whatever and mine tastes like famous and
you get it for 15 bucks how'd you do
that by tasting sitting it back sending
it back we have a Cabernet we have a
rose and we have a sauvignon blanc I
take it you're not a sauvignon blanc
Drinker no I'm not I'm not I'm became a
drinker you know dry red wines I don't
like anything sweet but I have those
three options for those who would like
to try Patti LaBelle why
how is being a successful entrepreneur
different than being a successful
musician how are the challenges how does
it compare oh God they're totally
different
because with the music with the song I
know when I sing it what it's going to
be I don't have to test that with the
food I have to test everything that I
put out 10 20 times sometimes one time
and I know it's great but when I go in
the studio or on stage I know what's
going to come out it's gonna be good
I have to test those tools to make sure
they're great before they go into the
stores you know into the markets so
that's the difference I have to do a lot
of tasting with the food to make sure
you're going to get a great meal
all of your business partners I've
talked to a few of them have
something before you say okay this is
good for Walmart I would test something
10 to 20 times it was uh what item was
that I tested the macaroni and cheese
about 12 times wow oh honey that cheese
has to be right and it has to pull you
know when you have a pizza or macaroni
you know how that cheese pulls when you
bring it to your mouth
that's that macaroni was tested about 12
times wow and it's so good yeah one of
the people who told me that you like to
test a lot is one of your co-packers one
of your manufacturers Nancy Nancy oh
she's been over here so it got to the
point where I said baby this is not
working I said can you come to Philly
and so she said sure So she came and we
went through the stove and tested many
many times of the macaroni we tested a
lot and until that cheese was pulling
properly because it was not going to
pull I'm not going to sell it how did
you choose her and your other partners
because it to make it successful
business you have to have successful
Partners what do you look for I have
successful people working with me who
believe in me like my son Zuri Charles
and Alex
I mean it's all Patty and nothing at all
it's just Patty and they know that
whatever I present and whatever I send
them out to do they're going to do it
and bring it back to me to taste and
make sure it's great
so whenever you see my name on something
know that I've tasted it all as far as
food and whenever you hear me sing you
know that I didn't have to test that
it's a given it's a gift but sometimes
that food could could trick you it might
not taste great all the time it's like
I've been cooking every day this week
and everything I cooked to me was gross
I said Pappy where's your touch and I've
been out on the road a bit and I came
home and lost my cooking skills it
happens even to the great Patti LaBelle
yeah but my friends and who tasted it
said it's great I said no it's not
that's not it because I know when it's
not great
now you had a line of clothing with HSN
in the early 2000s what did you learn
from that business experience
from that business business experience
that you can't lie you can't pretend
something's good to you when it's really
not I didn't really love everything but
I had a perfume I had dresses I had hats
I said I would never wear that hat why
am I selling it and I set it on a show
my son got so mad at me mom why did you
say that I said because it's true
and it's embarrassing too because I I
said yes to something that I wouldn't
wouldn't wear like Yes to the Dress when
you know you won't
you know I learned to be honest so with
everything you see with my name on it
coming from my heart
it's coming straight from my heart there
are so many people who like what I
didn't love
with my clothing line like big hats I
don't like them
um
certain types of dresses
I wouldn't wear but somebody else would
so but I still
I still sold those items but not feeling
as if I could wear them so what it
really is I make things for others
you're making it for yourself and your
family with Patty's good life
it has to be perfect or it's not going
into stores like that pie would have
never made it into Walmart if it wasn't
perfect and it was like the pies that my
mother made back in the day and my
grandmother and they tasted just like
theirs when we finish with the process
and that's always so important to me
that things are lovable to me like I
love my products all of them
I would use everything that I produce
the HSN deal that was an endorsement
deal as well right you were like that
was a licensing deal whereas Patty's
good life you are an owner it's me it's
you it's me and I and I'm the boss
that's awesome they work for me these
guys what does ownership mean to you or
what does it mean to own this brand it
means something that I never thought
would happen to me it's like a miracle
like my owning some things that I love
and people are listening to me and
they're purchasing my items because they
believe if Patty's putting it out there
it must be great not good must be great
great and I'm an owner ownership is so
important you know I there are other
celebrities who will license the
business but you own this and I think
that is a model to some people that
that's a big deal because my owning my
product it's my name
I'm allowed now to give jobs to others
who you know in all the factories making
my peach cobblers and the macaroni and
I'm employing a lot of people which
makes me feel great like I have that
power now which is a wonderful thing to
take care of people what is your
aspiration for Patty's good life and
your wildest dreams what do you want it
to grow to I wanted to grow to
um
the best product in the world
and I understand that my pies are number
one around the world
and I just found that out so I want
everything to go like that pie is doing
I mean I want everything to be great
and this way I can keep employing people
and keep on giving great food quality
items and whatever I do it's going to be
honest and it's going to be so good
you're going to say oh I want that
you're building a legacy business and
I wonder are there people who buy it not
realizing that it's you who's behind a
lot of a lot of people there because my
picture is on the sweet potato pie
and there there's my friend
Diane she was at someone's house for
Thanksgiving
and they have this pie and she ate the
pie and she said oh that pie was so good
and she said after I ate it guess what I
said what your face was on the box and I
didn't know that you were selling pies
so I mean we're best friends and so it's
like a lot of people really don't
realize but 50 years in the future if
Patty's good life is around more people
might be buying it without necessarily
making the connection to you as a
musician how does that make you feel
that will be fine as long as they're
consuming that pie and loving it because
everybody's not going to even know who
Patti LaBelle is
my name out there with my food you know
after I leave this planet like my
grandkids will be running the business
and that's that's going to be a
wonderful moment for them to see how
grandma and daddy did it and now we're
taking over and and that makes me feel
so proud to know that when I leave that
doesn't leave it stays here forever
so it's a great thought you own Patty's
good life
you haven't needed outside investors
correct it's all the proceeds from the
your music career that's basically
bootstrapping this business would you
ever take outside investors heck yeah if
they're coming right
yeah if they come correctly yeah they're
coming I'm welcoming anybody
who would like to do something like that
with Patty's product you want to grow it
oh yeah forever like I said and when
it's left for my babies I mean
they'll live on with that wonderful
birthday grandma did this
we've talked about the ownership your
personal Mark you testing everything
the good ingredients what if you had to
point to one thing has made it so
successful
I think the honesty of Patti LaBelle
people trusting in me and most people
knew that I cooked way back in the day
like the entertainers and you know
before 208
um
I never thought I would
be the owner of my pies
I never thought that my pie would be
doing so well and I think it's because
people think of me as a chef not a chef
I'm sorry as a cook and someone who's
going to give him quality food
and so now they can get it you know at a
reasonable price and
it just makes me feel happy to know that
I made
a mark in the business of food I know
what I do with my career as a singer but
knowing how much this has grown
as my business
I am proud of myself and I'm proud of my
my guys
because we work hard at what anything
that's necessary to be done they're
going to put 150 into it and make sure
it happens so many things that I could
be happy and proud of we have a lot of
people watching this video who might
want to start their own business but
might not know what to do they might
want to quit their job and be an
entrepreneur for the first time what is
your advice to someone who wants to do
what you did and start a brand become an
entrepreneur
well you really have to know what you're
selling is great and but believe in
yourself and it's like you can't come
half stepping you have to come correct
because people will leave you really
fast if you come with the wrong products
you know so I believe and totally
believing in myself and my team I mean
without them
you know I'm singing most of the time
and they're making the deals so you have
to have somebody in your corner who
really wants to do the best for you and
it's not always good to judge the good
people and the bad people sometimes you
make mistakes but if you have a great
something that you want to do believe in
it and don't stop
and don't let anybody tell you you can't
do it I never knew I could sell that
many thoughts I had no clue yeah as a
musician you have an audience you have
fans as an entrepreneur you have
customers they're buying from you
what do you look at what do you call
them are they all customers fans is it
an audience how do you think about the
people who are consuming both your food
and your music as friends as friends
yeah why because my friends are in the
audience buying tickets
I don't call them fans I call them
friends because they know they're going
to get a great show when you buy a Patty
product
they're my friends because they believe
that I'm giving them the best the
quality that they deserve
and so I call them all friends
everyone's a friend yeah
and they're fans Not fans no that sounds
too distant yes it is it's too far away
from me fans
I like Fred
well in the City of Brotherly Love it's
a good way to think about that right and
I think about it like that it's um when
the audience come there all my friends
out there some of them never saw my show
before but they become friends as I'm 90
minutes they see who I am and they'll
come back
when you buy a Patty's product you'll
see how good it is and you'll come back
and buy another one
speaking of the City of Brotherly Love
you've described yourself as a girl from
Philly yeah how has staying here been
important to you and how has it helped
your career as a musician and as an
entrepreneur
well Philadelphia is the only thing I
know whenever I will go to California or
London or any place I always wanted to
come home to the square quiet
Philadelphia space it's quiet there's no
temptation
I I just love Philadelphia
and I've lived you know in other places
but this is it for me because Philly I
think Philly folks are kind of honest
they'll let you know like if somebody
comes to my show and starts booing me is
because they didn't like me and I said
that's your prerogative you've got some
food at a show no
but if it happened I would just keep on
saying I heard you say something really
interesting last year which is that you
don't necessarily feel like you've
arrived what when will you feel like you
Patti LaBelle have arrived it's funny
Kim asked me that question last night
she said what do you think of yourself
you know now that you've accomplished so
much
she said how do you feel I said I don't
really know how I feel
I really don't know how I feel
because I had sisters
who were I mean it's serious for me
they've died in their 40s three sisters
and I'm still here
one year from 80. and I'm accomplishing
things like this
and still performing and still bringing
friends out
and I don't know how I really feel
because they're not here to share all of
this greatness with me
you know thank God I have my son I have
my niece and nephew and my grandkids but
I don't have them to tell them look what
I did
because they always thought I was so
great
and when they all left things started
happening greater for me
and to see me now at 79 still moving
moving along and giving out great honest
stuff
I would like to share that with him but
like Kim said but you're here by
yourself not you have your family and
others but my sisters meant so much to
me and they always knew I could cook my
face off you know and um
so I'm so happy
that I'm here
in this place of success and business
so
ah God
that's it sounds like you're doing it in
their memory yeah in their honor yes
there's so many things that happen to me
that are great and
just to see where I am
and see where they're not
it makes me feel some type of way
I can imagine yeah
and this success can't bring them back
you know
it's like I had my little dog to talk to
he gives me joy and uh
it's like I just lost a nephew about
four days ago and that's heavy um and he
always loved my cooking more than
anything and if Michael could be here
now seeing me doing an interview with
you he would just be smiling so hard
still I have a lot of things to think
about but a lot of greatness around all
of the negative you know so it
some somehow it's going to balance out
but I have to say what I really feel
how do you keep perspective you seem
to have a healthy perspective on the
loss and the achievements I just keep on
keeping on for them
because they always knew that oh that I
was this fabulous woman that I was this
great cook and this great singer
and that that gives me a joy
you know how you can have joy and
sadness but the joy is there
because you know what it did for them
and it's doing it now for me so when Kim
asked me that question next week I might
have a real answer for
you have some time to figure it out
you have a lot of plans you have some
wine to get out you have new patties
Good Life Products I have a lot of stuff
coming out thank God
yeah so I I'm truly blessed I am
you know I I'm here talking to you
that's a blessing when you were in your
20s and 30s did you ever imagine your
career over the age of 50 and if so what
did you think you'd be doing and how
does the reality compare
oh God
over 50 I would hope that I would have
been singing with about
20 million gold records
things like that
um
knowing back then too that I was going
to be a chef or some kind of something
to do with food
I
I had a feeling it would be great you
had a feeling it would be I had a
feeling because I was making good hot
sauce
and then that led to roasting chickens
and doing all kind of good things
Branzino and just cooking my face off so
I knew that I would be a little
prosperous when it came to food more so
than singing really yeah so if someone
said pick one title for yourself
are you a musician first or are you a
cook first I'm a musician first okay I'm
a singer first but as far as I'm
concerned my seeing career is not what I
wanted to be yet
but my cooking is going places where my
singing career has not gone yet is being
over the age of 50 an advantage or a
disadvantage in your line of work it's
an advantage why because I'm I've seen
it all I've done it all
I can let younger girls like Beyonce and
Mariah Carey and all those little girls
who ask me questions about where I've
been I give them all the info because
I've been there done that and threw away
that t-shirt
and I can give them quality answers
I love being 79. you love it I love it
because of the advice you can give to
others no because I'm still standing not
because of the advice that I'm still in
my right mind
that's important and that's so important
though speaking of advice I did want to
ask for one piece of advice to women in
their 30s and 20s who feel like they
have to rush to accomplish everything
that they want to accomplish before the
age of 50 or even before the age of 30.
what would you tell those women that
could kill you oh stop rushing
you're only 30.
you know and you'll hurt yourself
rushing for your ambition to happen
and you're going to do everything maybe
the wrong things to make it happen that
soon
I mean I'm doing better at 79 than I did
at 30.
you know so I would say don't rush it
if it's to be it will be
I have not been rushing honey
if not you've been taking your time but
you also don't seem to be slowing down
oh I can't I can't slow down I can't I
won't slow down
foreign